[Music]
and
without further ado i'll hand over the
stage to tyler morgan wong
thank you amara hi everyone uh
thank you for coming and thank you
rstudio for inviting me to talk
my name is tyler morgenwall i'm the
developer of the rayshader package
i'm a researcher at ida in washington dc
and today i'm going to be talking to you
about
3d gg plots with ray shader
so first things first what do i hope you
get out of this talk
20 minutes from now i guarantee that
each and every one of you
will know how to create beautiful 3d gg
plots in just
a few lines of code i also guarantee
that the specific capability
is so straightforward that you won't
have to look up any additional
documentation to get started
even though ray shader has a great
package and website at rayshader.com
with extensive documentation and
examples
and finally i guarantee that by the end
of this talk
you'll be thinking to yourself wow that
guy really loves spinning 3d plots
i do so
what is ratiator i could start first by
describing it in words like a normal
person
but luckily this year i don't have to
because i have a great visual aid
created by the
unparalleled r studio artist in
residence allison horst
ray shader is a package designed to
create 2d and 3d visualizations in r
specializing in maps it includes a wide
variety of functions
here represented by fuzzy functional
monsters that help you build color and
annotate
and beautify your visualizations
specifically ray shader uses a technique
called ray tracing
in order to realistically simulate how
light falls on
3d models and landscapes on the left you
can see how ratiator calculates
the shadows cast by buildings in
philadelphia
using a combination of lidar data and
the sun calc package
to calculate the position of the sun in
the sky
ray shader can take these 2d maps and
then project them into 3d
as we see here on the right so ray
shader also includes functions that you
can apply post-processing effects to
enhance these 3d maps
here i've added a depth of field effect
to blur areas away from the focal point
as well as a camera vignetting effect to
add a subtle darkening around the edges
like you'd see in a dslr this 3d
visualization was created entirely in
r with no external software required
ratiator does all this with a
straightforward pipeable interface
where you use elevation data to generate
shadows and maps
here the hobart object at the top of the
chain
is simply a 2d array of elevation values
at every point
it's just an r matrix we use that first
to generate a
color layer add a water layer add some
shadow layers and then finally plot the
map
to project this map into 3d we simply
replace the plot map function
with the plot 3d function and include
the original matrix of height values
this function generates a 3d mesh
generated by the hobart matrix
and then paints the surface of it with
the output of everything above
if you want to learn more about all the
great mapping and 3d printing
features in ray shader i encourage you
to watch my r studio conference talk
from last year
additionally if you want a more
extensive introduction i have a freely
available master class i taught along
with the
musa program at the university of
pennsylvania that walks you through
several comprehensive examples
and there's video available of that as
well check out my github page to learn
more
so mapping is great but one thing i
always get when i
demo ratiaters people say i'd love to
have a reason to use that
but i don't work with geographic data so
let's say i wanted to extend ratiator to
work with
other types of data uh let's specific
or let's first specify what type of 3d
plot we want to work on
and generally when we talk about 3d
plots there are four common types we're
referring to
first is the 3d scatter plot which is a
bunch of points floating in space
second is the 3d line plot which is a
bunch of points floating in space
connected by lines third is the surface
plot which is a contiguous mesh of
points representing a solid
surface and finally is the abomination
which is what happens when you take a
plot that doesn't want to be 3d but you
pull it into
the third dimension anyway to make sure
we don't make any abominations
we'll only use 3d plots when we have
three continuous variables
variables we map to the x y and z
directions
we'll also avoid plots that involve data
floating in space as those suffer from
the inability of the reader to correctly
determine the depth of the points in
space
leading to ambiguities and interpreting
the data surface plots suffer far less
from this problem
since the regular grid gives the reader
more perceptual cues
to the data's spatial ordering we will
also remove the axes
which might seem heretical in dataviz
but axes in 3d don't work the same way
they do in 2d
you can't the viewer can't unambiguously
map the data back to their values
putting your 3d visualization in a box
rarely improves it
and if a visualization requires the axes
to be interpretable
it's likely not a good candidate for 3d
in the first place
so we're going to focus on surface plots
what's our interface going to look like
when you're creating a new software
package one good idea before you start
is the survey what tools are already out
there
this serves two purposes one to figure
out whether you even need to re
write your package whether the niche is
already filled and second to get
inspiration um
for what you your software should and
maybe shouldn't do
so what's the premiere tool out there
for 3d visualization currently
blender blender is a 3d modeling
rendering sculpting simulation visual
effects and
everything but the kitchen sync software
package open source
it's an extremely powerful piece of
software that produces absolutely
breathtaking 3d renderings including 3d
data visualizations
here are a few examples taken with
permission from artists
and cartographers who use blender to
visualize data
with gorgeous results there's a few
issues however
first blender is primarily a gui based
application
as you see here along with the text i
have added
and gui based workflows are not
reproducible
one of the benefits of using r to power
your visualization and analysis pipeline
is that you can reproduce old analyses
years after the fact
rerun the same exact analyses on new
batches of data and make slight changes
to figures without having to redo the
entire thing
there's a python interface to blender
but it's primarily aimed at developers
not at data scientists and analysts data
is not a first-class citizen
additionally you're here at this
conference because you've at least
somewhat invested yourself in the our
ecosystem
you're you've taken workshops read
tutorials and presumably have spent a
good
deal of time becoming familiar and maybe
even an expert in r
and all of those skills will be
absolutely useless
when it comes to learning blender um
except for maybe robust anger management
techniques
which if you saw jenny bryan's keynote
this morning you'll know the frustration
of seeing
object of type closure is not subsetable
for the first time
so it's a stretch to ask most people to
learn one complex piece
of software learning too to perform a
single task
makes that task inaccessible to all but
the most perseverant of individuals
so for a surface plotting api i have a
few goals in mind
first and foremost you should never have
to think about vertices or
triangles or polygons i want a 3d
plotting interface that's focused around
data
not computer graphics secondly i want to
avoid introducing new interfaces you'll
have to learn
i want to use as much as what you
already know to lower the barrier to
entry for using the software
and finally i want the interface to be
friendly and simple enough that people
feel like they can play with it
because play and experimentation is a
fuel for creativity and learning
and what fills all these requirements
ggplot
it's a plotting library that's data
centric well known by many people
and easy to experiment with so you might
be asking
wait plot 2 is a 2d plotting library
is there a gg plot 3 i don't know about
no but i'll tell you how you can
transform into 3d
um recall what i said earlier to plot a
3d surface all you need are three
variables that we map to the x
y and z directions the x and y
aesthetics are built into ggplot
and we encode the third aesthetic
representing height to color
and then we've encoded all three
variables into our 3d serve of our 3d
surface into our gg plot
images are generally speaking several
matrices just layered together
each which specifies a color intensity
so even an
image can be a height matrix
for better or for worse sorry hadley
um the plot 3d function which performs
all the 3d mapping logic
only cares that it's past the matrix of
height values in an image
if we encode our data into one of those
color layers we can then extract
a matrix of height values from our gg
plot and create a 3d surface onto which
we can paint our data
by swapping the ggpot's palette to a
grayscale black and white palette
it ensures we have a one-to-one
relationship between our data and our
height value
we then strip out all the non-color
elements and non-data elements axes
labels backgrounds text
and our grayscale image now represents
the height map of the surface
we then drop this into plot3d along with
the
plot texture and now we have our 3d gg
plot
you might ask wait you guaranteed me
little to no
effort on my part stripping out all
these themes
theme elements seems like a lot of
effort and it is
which is why i automated the entire
process into a single function
plot gg you just pass in the ggplot
object
and it transforms it into a 3d surface
no
no uh other work required no drawing
polygons
no fiddling with complex guise just one
simple api to call
drop in your gg plot and watch it grow
plot gg works with both the color and
fill aesthetics
and ray shader automatically detects
which one you used uh here i use the
color aesthetic
to uh in a point geom which
is then projected to 3d if you have a
complex plot that uses both you can
specify and plot gg which one to use
so plot 3d plots are best seen in motion
and ray shader includes several
functions that you can use to bring your
viewers on a tour through your data
you can use the render camera and render
movie functions
to pass a series of camera angles to
swing around your data set so you can
zoom in around
and save your uh your movie to a file to
share online or
with a loved one
so you can also use render snapshot
function to take a picture of the
current orientation
but if you want the user to focus or the
viewer to focus on a certain area
you can use the same trick
cinematographers use when they want to
direct a viewer's attention in a movie
use depth of field to pull focus onto an
area of interest
onto the area of interest with the
render depth function
you can also add titles and tech image
overlays when taking snapshots and
rendering movies here i added a title to
describe this plot which is the classic
public health london cholera data set
here visualizing the number of nearest
neighbors at infection sites
so i added this legend as an overlay to
clearly label the number of near
nearest neighbors um so that's this
thing up here
i also use the render label function in
radiator to add a
floating text label at the site of the
water pump where the infection
site is being spread from um
some might say that it's improper to mop
the map the same variable to two
separate aesthetics
this visualization is showing the number
of measles cases in the world reported
by the who
mapped to both color and height which is
a redundant mapping
but redundancy can be good because it
can improve the accessibility and
interpretability of our plots
3d plots have some downside data can
obscure other data behind it view some
perspective can make comparisons between
data points harder if there's a lot of
spatial derivative variation in depth
and the use of perspective can uh and
sorry the users generally lose the
ability to pull out the exact values of
the z-axis
however it also has some perceptual
advantages over color
um color perception varies from person
to person so white might be an obvious
difference between
one person might not be to another and
additionally how our eyes interpret
color is highly non-linear
and even if you pick a good palette like
those in the virtus package
as we have here readers have to
understand how to read and reference a
color bar which not all people do
3d plots make it easy to spot outliers
and make rough relative comparisons
between values
using both color and height can get you
the best of both worlds
and if you have a truly complex
visualization where the 3d difference
surface is actually different than the
data you're showing ratiater allows you
to do that as well
this plot is a simulation of a moon
disrupting a ring of satellites
visualizing both the motion of the
particles as well as the shape of the
gravitational potential well
showing how the satellites are falling
into the potential well is far more
illustrative than showing
both the 2d plots and creating this
visualization and
was straightforward with plot gg instead
of passing in a single gg plot
we just pass in a list of two gg plots
the first is the texture that's painted
on the surface and the second one is
used that you
use to project it to 3d uh here you can
see it in action
along with the beautiful resulting
animation
now some of you might not be convinced
because while these plots are cool
and the api is simple they don't have
the same visual impact as the plots
produced by blunder
and that's true because blender has a
realistic rendering algorithm called
path tracing
that can produce photorealistic results
because it actually simulates how light
travels through the scene ratiater
relies on the rgl package for rendering
which uses a faster
but less visually striking method called
rasterization
in order to get visualizations that look
as good as blender as those produced by
blender
i would have to write my own path tracer
entirely in r from scratch
integrate it into ratiator and then get
it on the crayon
which i did
so introducing render high quality uh
array shader function that calls a
built-in
integrated path tracer to render
absolutely stunning 3d data
visualizations
and the api is dead simple it takes your
current ratio view or just call the
function
it takes your current ratio view
transparently exports it to a built-in
path tracer
and renders it with realistic light
transport no complicated gooeys to learn
no long walkthroughs or tutorials to
slog through no need to even learn how
path tracing works
just call and just create a 3d plot with
radiator call the function
and see your data in a new light
speaking of light you have absolutely
full control over how the scene is lit
you can customize the color direction
intensity
number of lights as well as drop in your
own lights wherever you see fit
you gain full artistic control over how
your visualization looks
here i've added a wandering 3d light
traveling at a figure eight around
hobart tasmania
this is all powered by the ray render
package which i won't get into here
because it's an entire talk on its own
but whether you want to plot a t-rex or
a teapot
make bounce the dvd logo exclusively
into the corner 100 percent of the time
create your own gold medal for best
pokemon master
or just render 30 to 50 50 feral pigs on
their own lonely planet
you can do it with ray render all
entirely within r
and you can use ray render with ray
shader to add the freedom to add
whatever you want to your visualization
render high quality supports adding 3d
models to your 3d ratio data
if you want to add a pig to your map
well i'm not going to stop you and in
fact i encourage it
while this particular pig was added just
for fun this capability can be used to
augment and enhance your the story your
visualization
is trying to tell let me show you how
you can combine all of this all of these
capabilities all into one
awesome example here we start with a
regular ray shader version of the space
time plot i showed you earlier
a nice 3d view but we can do better
we're using render snapshot to capture
frames for our movie but let's switch
to render high quality instead
that gives us beautiful ray trace
shadows and realistic light transport
but let's go one step further we can use
ray render to pass in
additional objects and to render high
quality here to drop an actual 3d planet
moon and asteroid belt into the
visualization
and we can animate it this is all done
entirely within r simulation plotting
and rendering
so it's entirely reproducible
so in summary transform your gg plots
into 3d using ray shader
feel free to experiment with plot gg and
see what you've come up with
and if you come up with something cool
be sure to post it on twitter with the
hashtag rayshader
rstats if you want to impress your peers
and show how r
is truly the coolest language for 3d
visualization
take render high quality for a spin um
for more information documentation and
examples check out ray shader's website
at ratiater.com
rayrender's website at rayrender.net my
own personal blog some very in-depth
examples at tylermw.com
get the code and check out my master
class on github and find me during the
rest of the day to get a ratiate or hex
sticker
and check me out on twitter at
tylermorganwall for a constant stream of
awesome 3d visualizations
and updates thank you so much
thank you so much tyler i think you uh
just covered the most popular question
which is
where can we get the ratio hex sticker
great just find me i have 100 and about
200 left so
definitely find them is spinning the
default behavior of the 3d plots or can
we click and drag to explore
different stationary angles yes you can
click and drag
you rgl you can just click you can
spinning is just one of the options in
render movie
so you can change the camera angle to
whatever you want
do we need a fancy graphics card no
it no not at all it should work on uh it
should work on whatever computer it
doesn't use your gpu at all
is ray shader compatible with shiny
slash flex dashboard
okay
so there is a way you can use it you can
export it currently to a webgl
object which you can then it'll render
in there there are some shiny apps that
show this
um one of the projects i have for the
next year is i've already included gltf
export in a
in the dev version i have that i'm going
to include as an expert that's a
web transmittable format um so i'm going
to have that and the other issue with
shiny is if you're running it on a
server
a ray shader currently uses rgl which
doesn't support headless operation
so you can't take snapshots um but
that's something i'm also working i have
some projects working on so
can layers be added to ratio maps such
as roads or structure
yes so there's an add overlay function
watch my talk from last year
but yes there's an ad overlay function
and there's a great package called
geoviz which allows you to add floating
lines
um to for movement tracks um
paragliding tracks gps tracks a lot of
people have done some very cool stuff
with that
does ratio play well with gg animate no
that that's also a future plot a future
future goal
great um i'm sure you've never heard
this one before
raciater scientists spend a lot of time
asking if they could
did they also also ask if they should
yes so go go to my blog read my
um read my blog post where i talk about
3d gg plots with ratiater and i do talk
about some of the uh
some of the thoughts for why i think
that 3d can be good
um and i think one of the issues with 3d
is really it's more been about the
tooling hasn't supported over
through the years so i think that's a
kind of key part that's been missing so
you know when the tooling mostly
supports 3d pie charts
you're going to get a lot of bad plots
but if the tooling supports something
better then i think that's uh
that's what i'm trying to do at least
great a couple more
um how long does it take for the movies
to render and i'll just add to that
what's the average temperature of your
computer
so so when i'm doing the so the non-ray
traced and path traced ones they're
pretty quick you can get one of those in
under a few minutes
um if as long as it's not too large the
ray traced ones uh well my computer sits
at 100
c the entire for like eight hours
straight it's probably not good it's
gonna kill my computer
so yeah it depends on the quality though
you can adjust the number of samples
that um to get a lower quality if you
want to just want to demo something out
but when you render something with a
path tracer
it's like you know six to eight hours
for a
12 second video so yes a long time
and then last one is where can we find
good 3d geospatial data
to practice with so if you go to my
master class i actually have
five data guides that list data for the
entire world
uh the us several cities it gives you
instructions on how to extract
height data from lidar which includes
buildings um and it's uh i give you
very very detailed instructions on
exactly what to click and how to get the
data
so you can easily create uh whatever map
you want
great well let's have another round of
applause for tyler thanks so much
thank you